good afternoon and welcome to the world
leaders forum at Columbia University we
are very honored to be joined here today
by monkey moon secretary-general of the
United Nations the secretary-general
speech opens the 6th global colloquium
of university presidents this year's
colloquium is focused on the global
effects of the youth population surge
and will attempt to address the needs of
the largest generation of young people
the world has ever known
for those not familiar with the genesis
of the global colloquium of university
presidents the effort came in response
to the United Nations expressed interest
in engaging the global academic
community to explore international
public policy concerns the first global
colloquium was held at Columbia in
January of 2005 and it addressed issues
of academic freedom and of migration
policy in the years since the global
colloquium has been hosted by each of
the five founding universities located
in the Northeast United States and
addressing other subjects such as
climate change the role of Science in
meeting global challenges and last
year's meeting on gender equality and
empowering women I want to recognize the
former presidents in this and/or the
founding presidents in this endeavor who
have been such gracious and generous
hosts to the colloquium in previous
years Amy Gutmann
president of the University of
Pennsylvania Richard Levin president of
Yale John Sexton president of NYU and
Shirley Tilghman president of Princeton
and finally I want to extend a warm
welcome to the president's and faculty
of 24 leading universities who have
traveled from 19
nations and five continents to be with
us today but not finally I also want to
recognize madam bond would you please
stand so that we could say welcome to
you
at the time of the first global
colloquium I said that in these days of
rapid globalization and a more
interconnected world we have a
tremendous responsibility to lend our
collective scholarship and expertise
toward the resolution of challenges
worldwide and that remains precisely the
rationale for this gathering today when
one pauses to consider the vast
potential for intellectual discovery and
for advancing the public good
represented by the institution's
assembled here the sense of social
responsibility felt by every leader of a
major university becomes easy to
understand
since beginning of becoming
secretary-general in 2007 Ban ki-moon
has been an inspirational leader of the
United Nations
he speaks often of his childhood in
Korea the experience of coping with the
violence of war his families forced
expulsion from its home and the
resulting life of poverty the role of
the United Nations forces in rescuing
and restoring his country instilled in
Ban ki-moon a profound belief in the
power of the international community to
alleviate injustice and suffering and he
chose to dedicate his professional life
to the diplomatic core ultimately
serving as South Korea's foreign
minister as Secretary General Ban Ki
moon has promoted sustainable
development strengthen poverty fighting
programs and worked for gender equality
and empowering girls and women through
education he has been unwavering in
standing against intolerance and
oppression including last month when he
spoke out strongly and unequivocally
against violence and discrimination
based on sexual orientation at a meeting
of the Human Rights Council in Geneva
the secretary-general has also provided
leadership on the subject of this
colloquium the global surge in the youth
population there are nearly three
billion people living today who are
under the age of 25 that constitutes
almost one half of the world's
population it is not uncommon to find
nations of the global south with as much
as 40 percent of their population
between the ages of 15 and 29 this
particular demographic reality will be
with us for some time the surge in the
youth population can be either an asset
or a liability for a country struggling
to find its economic footing and build
its civic institutions if nations invest
in infrastructure and education reform
labor laws commit to job training and
allow for meaningful democratic
engagement then the presence of a large
youth cohort can stimulate economic
growth while driving political reform
and modernization replacing rote
learning techniques with curricula that
develop critical thinking skills is
recognized by leaders around the world
to be critical to such progress and
liberalizing migration policies can help
reduce labor shortages and surpluses
across the nations of the global north
and the global south but without policy
prescriptions appropriate to this the
dem current demographic situation can
become a source of conflict and
instability the prospects for every
nation experiencing a surge in its youth
population will turn heavily on the
availability of meaningful opportunities
for employment education and political
participation recognising the importance
of this challenge UN habitat and the UN
Development Programme organized the
youth 21 Global Initiative and convened
a four-day meeting
in Nairobi last month the
secretary-general has announced that he
will be appointing a special advisor on
youth and he has made the needs of the
rising youth poppy
elation a top priority of his five-year
agenda ladies and gentlemen please help
me welcome the secretary-general of the
United Nations Ban ki-moon
Thank You president Bollinger for your
very kind introduction distinguished
university presidents esteemed the
faculty students and other members of
the Columbia University community
ladies and gentlemen it's a great honor
and pleasure to be with you this evening
to discuss about our common challenges
and facing many young students here and
first of all before I begin and go into
further details I hope you will be a
patient with my voice this is quite
embarrassing moment for me I was a
traveling six countries last week I came
back last Friday traveling in warm
countries and cold country then hot
countries normally one catch is called
not in cold weather one catch is called
in hot weather because of air
conditioning so some people told me that
my voice is something like froggy
it's very horse sound I hope you will be
patient for about 20-25 minutes I'll try
to speak softly as much as I can as in
every year this colloquium global
colloquium addresses some of the most
pressing issues facing our world and
United Nations has been working very
closely with this global colloquium
particularly with founding presence of
this colloquium I have been honored to
join a number of times so I know how
dynamic this forum is and how much you
can achieve and thank you for having me
back I am especially happy that this
year we'll be talking about
youth with the youth today I look
forward to a dialogue to the video this
beautiful rotunda has seen many
traumatic events including the protest
back in 1968 I'm not endorsing those
protests but I remember the time when I
was myself 23 and I was also protesting
from different place the circumstances
were different from here and there but
in both cases young people were seeking
change they were speaking out for their
genuine legitimate rights and
opportunities which were not given to
them I mentioned because when we talk
about youth we have to look beyond
demographics to why young people are so
powerful youth are often the first to
stand for principles and against
injustice youth is a time of idealism
young people are a forceful
transformation these are timeless
qualities but today's younger
generations has a new advantage you have
the Internet Twitter's but as a child
when I first saw a television it was
early 1960s I put my hand on the screen
because I was so fascinated now when my
grandchildren see a TV they put their
hand on the screen because they expected
to respond to their comment young people
are using social networking to
drastically alter power dynamics
some tea taters in our world are more
afraid of twits than they are of
opposing armies young people are using
Facebook and Twitter to organize a
protest speak out against the human
rights abuses and end operation if I may
say something about my career when and
these young people were demonstrating
they were going far ahead of policemen
because they are communicating with all
these emails and Twitter's they know
exactly where police were advancing so
they were outpacing the police this is
something which are being used but I'm
not talking about all these
demonstrations but I'm trying to tell
that how much these young people young
generation are creative and I
wholeheartedly welcome this kind of a
phenomenon at the University of Kansas
students are designing social media
strategies for United Nations campaigns
that we are going to send to all of our
offices around the world and those
students are going to create a flash mob
on campus to promote interest in the
United Nations I wish I could be there
young people everywhere deserve the
power to get information connect and ask
hard questions about justice equality
and opportunity our job is to listen to
youth and answer their calls and today I
brought you some messages we gathered
from young people on social justice and
decent work one was concerned about her
future maybe this sounds familiar she
said I caught you graduate from a good
university you passed up with the high
flying colors
and yet you do not have opportunities
there you wonder what went wrong another
young woman said with the lack of money
poverty and hunger it is very difficult
to keep your dreams alive this is real
story and the young one young man said
like what if I sit around I'm wasting my
time but I feel like even even if I'm
looking for a job I'm still wasting my
time so I don't know what to do anymore
I share these voices of young people
because we cannot just make speeches
saying we should listen to young people
we have to actually hear from them but
this is a dialogue so I also want to
share some of what I have learned from
the university presidents in this room
yes I have read your papers you describe
youth as a social challenge you stress
the significance of youth empowerment to
the prosperity of the nation and you
acknowledged that I quote access to
higher education is not an automatic
guarantee of having access to work and
of course maybe maybe if I put foot a
lot in my speech you will give me an A
grade but actually I would prefer to get
an e why because this is the letter I
want you to remember today I'll speak
about three years three years education
employment and empowerment education is
true progress
I'm often asked by many people during
last many years as a second general or
40 minutes of career
knowing that Korea has developed in such
a short period of time they always ask
easy question what is the secret of
Korean Democratic maturity and economic
development many African leaders
compared with the South Korea their
level of development in nineteen
nineteen sixty many Africans were better
than or similar to the level of South
Korea at that time
after fifty years there's a huge gap
than they are asking these questions
without hesitation I say that is owing
to education wise smart investment in
education Korea wisely invested in
education early on that care of the
country a knowledgeable skilled
workforce by the time the industrial era
industrialization phase had took off in
Korea I'm not here to talk about Korea
but I'm just giving you an example Korea
continued investing in education and
this continued to pay great returns in
prosperity stability and Happiness
around the world countries are bringing
more children into classrooms you might
have heard that President Obama on many
occasions during last three years he has
mentioned the Korean success story in
education but worldwide more than 125
million people young people cannot read
or write two thirds of these illiterate
people are women this is a problem for
those billions of individuals but it is
also our problem United Nations problem
and I think your problem particularly
Americans who is the richest and the
leader of this this world why because
when we hold women back so many women
back we hurt progress for all people I'm
convinced and I say this everywhere I go
that investing in education for girls
and women is the key to unlocking
advances across a society that is why I
have made education one of my top
priorities in the next five years
we especially have to focus on girls
a girl will never get the opportunities
she deserves is one less scientist
discovering a breakthrough
one less a peacemaker negotiating a
ceasefire and one less university
president helping to shape a better
future the United Nations is working to
get more girls in schools
but around the world at least 67 million
young people including boys and girls
are out of school at this time we have
to address a gender inequality and we
have to look at other in Justices
migrants persons with disabilities
refugees and other marginalized young
people struggle just to want to class
learning can be a matter of life or
death
especially when it comes to information
on reproductive health every minute and
a half
90 seconds a woman dies in pregnancy or
childbirth many of them are just
teenagers they live their lives could be
saved with the right information and
surprise every minute somewhere in the
world
a young woman is infected with HIV until
they develop a vaccine for the virus the
best protection is education last year I
went to health clinics in Nigeria
Ethiopia Bangladesh Thailand and
Indonesia
I saw firsthand the value of educating
women to provide care for the community
in the community ladies and gentlemen
the second II is employment there are
nearly 74 million people young people
who are jobless in our world I was in
Baghdad last week for a summit meeting
of the Arab League the unrest in North
Africa and the Middle East was driven
partly by the lack of opportunity and
freedom in the next decade in ten years
Arab countries need to create 15 million
jobs for new people joining the
workforce the Arab Spring or Arab
Awakening was a season of hope and
expectation at the time I told the
region's leader listen to your people
they were not only talking about
democracy many young people were looking
for a better future with the teason jobs
and decent pay billions of youth work in
unsafe conditions they have no benefits
no job security and limited rights
young people may be resilient but they
should never be exploited the opposite
we should be doing everything possible
to encourage their potential the United
Nations international labor organization
known as iro
we hold the conference odyssia on youth
employment scores of young people will
be there to face problems and to find
solutions beyond conferences we need
action to create development that is
rich in jobs for young people youth
deserve an education and employment but
every young people also needs
empowerment that is my third II
empowerment to unleash the power of
young people we need to partner with
them this is what the United Nations is
trying to do we are developing an action
plan for the coming years we want to
work with youth on major issues
affecting them including Japanese
political inclusion human rights and
sexual health I have also decided to
appoint as president Bollinger said a
special advisor on north this will be
the first time that the United Nations
is going to appoint a special advisor of
the secretary-general after I made the
announcement youth organizations with
100 million members wrote me a letter
they said I quote it is up to you to
prove that the United Nations commitment
to empower young people is what you
believe in and what you are striving for
I take these words very seriously we
want you to be part of the upcoming UN
conference on sustainable development
known as Rio +20 this is once in a
generation opportunity to create future
we want to the students I say what is
the future you want think about it ask
your friends
bring your ideas to the United Nations
get engaged this is your moment all the
issues has taken view climate change
scarcity of water food and energy and
the health of our planet and gender
empowerment and health of Ocean
urbanization you name all these global
issues that the other Janeiro will try
to imagine a global movement for the
future we want to the university
president among you I ask for your
partnership consider joining United
Nations academic impact an initiative
that brings higher education and the UN
system together above all you have the
responsibility the president of
University and professors to train your
students to think globally to inspire
your students to go out in the world and
to work not only for the betterment of
their own country but the betterment of
all humankind and I'm telling the young
students here broaden your scope broaden
your vision copyin the United States or
copy and loop Ian where you are coming
from this world is wide and there are so
many things to do for you even though
you may have your own concern at this
time try to see beyond the boundary of
the United States loopy and all what you
can contribute to global challenges be a
global citizen that's my message to you
in an era where social inequalities are
growing we need to build resilience and
equality with wider vision and the way
to do that is help youth and women
ladies and gentlemen all danyoung but
especially old I have spoken today about
youth because I believe we can change
what is often called a population
explosion into a global transformation
but let me say a word to the elders in
the room after all I am one of you in
fact it's a fashionable to say youth is
a state of mind people like this
expression because it implies that we
can always be young I still think I'm as
young as a 20 years old my heart is but
I know that I have aged I am getting old
but I'm trying to think as young people
do this is only consolation which I can
have but I would frame it differently
youth is a state of mind is not the
consolation is a challenge youth are an
idealistic and brave they do not come up
to Authority I'm not young I admit but I
recently had a chance to speak about an
issue where too many people have been
silent
the terrible violence and discrimination
against people who are lesbian gay
bisexual and transgender last month we
had the first-ever
formal UN debate on this issue like many
people of my generation I did not grow
up talking about sexual orientation at
that time that's kind of some taboo in
my generation when I was young in Korea
but I learned to speak speak out because
lives are at stake when I spoke out
delegates from some 50 countries walked
out of the conference room in protest
this was the first time then our second
general speaks the people just went out
it was an embarrassment but I think I
did right things to do they did not want
the council to even discuss the issue
but this is the right time to talk about
human rights of those people who are
being discriminated because of sexual
orientation my message to them is up on
YouTube and I hope they hear it after I
spoke up for my belief I received a
great praise from some and booter
criticism from others when my response
to both was the same human rights are
human rights human beings are human
beings I'm not in this job just for the
easy issues where everyone already
agrees my point is we can all be young
in our attitude the determination to
right wrongs that drives young people
can motivate all of us all of you in
this room today know this and all of you
in this room share these values and
cultures
and I thank you very much for your
attention and patience and I look
forward to hearing from you on how we
can advance together how we can shape
the future we want how we can realize
the dreams where every man rich or small
rich or poor where somebody is from big
or small country young or young or old
can live without any fear can live
always with freedom of speech freedom of
assembly and good ideas to make this
world better for all and I thank you
very much
are you open any questions or
thank you very much mr. secretary
general and especially under the
conditions of your cold and sore throat
we very much appreciate it will now open
this up to questions there are
microphones on either side in the aisles
and this is an opportunity principally
for students to be able to ask questions
but let me begin by picking up on the
last theme of young people developing a
capacity for global thought and to
approach being a global citizen I wonder
if you could say something about how
that happened to you
obviously by being secretary-general of
the United Nations that's a good good
way to become a global citizen but not
everybody here is the young people are
going to become secretary-general after
you graduated from university in Seoul
how did you develop a sense of a global
mind I was I think I have been lucky
because my job as a diplomat has to
always engage with different different
group of people basically diplomats are
coming from different countries with
different ideas that different
background 37 years of my life as a
Korean diplomat has broadened naturally
my vision and my way of thinking my way
of most importantly understanding
understanding of the issues and
understanding over different different
people's problems and that is the way I
was able to cultivate that my capacity
as being a global citizen why I am
asking you is that you are more or less
living in the same country either
America or Asia or somewhere just try to
look beyond beyond your dish
boundaries otherwise you will not be
able to cultivate your capacity to
become a global citizen now we need a
global citizen there is no boundary in
fact for example when you address
climate change then climate change
doesn't respect any border it impacts
all around the world so you are just a
part of this global global world planet
Earth so let us be a global citizen
that's my message again today thank you
yes hi my name is Joanna hi Yunshan
thank you for your time today I have a
background in architecture in human
rights which led me to become a strong
believer that infrastructural change and
the sharing of architectural knowledge
can bring about great change such as
providing access to resources such as
clean drinking water or preventing
disasters such as the aftermath of Haiti
could I ask you for more insight on how
you see south-south cooperation of
sharing architectural technology as
providing better better living
conditions for youth around the world
the world is suffering from a shortage
of food particularly in 2008 world
suffered began to suffer from food
crisis and why this food crisis happens
I believe that world has enough food to
eat to eat for all seven billion people
to eat there is a serious problem of
distribution and we cannot control all
this distribution but in any way we have
to address this food crisis by raising
the productivity of Agriculture I have
been working very very hard by
establishing a global task force which I
have been a chairing during last four
years
maybe more than 25 times I have convened
this I have been talking with the World
Bank IMF oacd an African Development
Bank and its Europeans as well as Arab
development and with government and FAO
and all these food-related agencies we
have to provide tools to many small
holder farmers in Africa in many
developing world they do not have first
of all weather resistant seeds they do
not have a fertilizers they do not have
good information for farming on top of
this climate change has impacted on top
of this water scarcity has deteriorated
it wasn't these agricultural
productivity issues we are working very
hard to comprehensively address the
decision to address all these issues
like water scarcity food crisis energy
we are working as I said we approach 27
meeting which will be held in June in
Rio de Janeiro will provide us a very
good opportunity once-in-a-generation
opportunity to address all these issues
including agricultural production issues
thank you thank you yes good afternoon
mr. ban ki-moon your excellency thank
you for this opportunity and for coming
to Columbia University and speaking with
us about the young generation my name is
Esperanza Garcia I'm the president of
Columbia University Coalition for
sustainable development I'm also the
co-founder of International Youth
Council which is found at the Internet
at the Youth Assembly of the United
Nations an event of which I organized I
have represented my country the
Philippines in UN climate change
negotiations bring the voice of young
people in an international multilateral
negotiation
that affects her future I'd like to
thank you as you had mentioned we do not
have the power we do not have the
authority and yet we have people like
you who represent us in such an
important process because not only does
it affect our young generation it
affects the generations after us as well
i and the team at Columbia University
are attending Rio +20 as Columbia
University coalition sustainable
development along with many other young
generations to build the future we bond
we are also planning New York +20
alongside informal informal negotiations
in April what I'd only ask for you mr.
ban ki-moon is not only to help as you
are already doing young voices such as
the major groups of children and youth
at the upcoming Rio +20 conference but
I'm also asking for world leaders to
look in how we can implement these
policies and how these policies can be
implemented in terms of financing in
real terms because having negotiated in
UN climate negotiations of which I was
the youngest delegate in the g77 in
China which we succeeded building
article 6 which built education and and
and and promoted education and climate
change and yet it's always about the
implementation and how these can be HAP
this can happen and so that's all like
we asked of you is just see how you can
have a strongest policy in place but all
it needs is a way of implementing thank
you very much thank you
I like that passion you know I like
passion of young people in all global
issues you're not just learning or
you're not just studying the books you
need to develop your capacity to address
all these issues which are now happening
which will affect your future that is
why it is only natural only legitimate
for you to be concerned and to speak out
about this climate change and
sustainable development now let me tell
you more about only the sustainable
development in Rio +20 international
community has been really suffering from
all these global challenges we have you
have been really consuming all the
resources in the name of prosperity in
the name of consumptions then I believe
that international community we have
almost reached the limit of planetary
limit one should know that there is a
limit in this planet we have only one
planet Earth and the resources are
limited without knowing this simple fact
we have burned all these resources to
prosperity that we cannot do anymore
the old model cannot walk any anymore
that's why we are now really trying to
make this sustainable development a
great success for the humanity we have
been dealing with the climate change but
not only enough it was only just
recently that international community
has been discussing about climate change
when I became secretary in 2007 it was
not this issue was not all our you know
list
I put this to the high highest point
place in our global agenda but we have
not reached it there and there is a food
crisis issue which I have explained
there is a serious energy shortages
energy is cross-cutting issues in
addressing all our challenges without
electricity without decent energy how
can you achieve all your
industrialization program or science or
whatever then there is a very serious
water scarcity issues worldwide there is
at least one point two billion people do
not have access to safe drinking water
at least the 1.4 billion people do not
have electricity we have to get
eliminate this kind of situation and the
oceans are getting sick and sick every
day there is a serious maritime
environment issues the urbanization this
again creates a huge problems so our
vision is to address all these global
challenges in a more comprehensive way
more integrated manner from a broader
perspective let us address all this
issue in food once in one threat
in one threat which has been dealt with
in a separate separate venues this is
our basic concept I think climate change
should be the entry point the most
important point among all these global
challenges and how we can address all
these challenges we have to have energy
energy can solve this problem energy can
be the most effective tools if we have
decent energy by all seven billion
people without shortages then this will
really accelerate our capacity to
address climate change issues water
issues
food production issues and sanitation
and addressing these global disease
issues so let us really try to shape our
future by ourselves I think your passion
your vision is very important the young
people should have this passion when
young people do not have passion you had
no longer young I thank you very much
for that yes good afternoon Secretary
General
my name is Bruno Mendes and I'm a
sophomore in the college I'm in
international politics students and
there are many issues on international
politics on which I would like to hear
your thoughts but I was particularly
moved by the fact that you stood out for
LGBT Hugh's QA students and humans
worldwide and that leads me to ask how
do you think the UN can work to address
such human rights rights issues given
the fact that many leaders leaders of
countries even refused to talk about
them thank you as a secretary general I
have been traveling many countries
around the world during the last five
years I have visited at least 120
countries just a unit by when you talk
about some countries where I have been
visiting ten times that will be counted
one by this count I have visited 120
countries that means maybe if I multiply
this I might have 5500 countries in five
years maybe then I have seen I have met
so many people whose basic human rights
are just brutally abused neglected is
the elected is in a much better
condition
abused and crushed those are LGBTQ they
are one of them they were very afraid of
to you know show that they are having
this kind of a sexual orientation there
are many people with physical
disabilities whose opportunities have
been again and D collected and abused
there are many young girls and women
particularly their human rights have
been not been protected I really wanted
to speak out for them when I was a
visiting Malawi I read an article that
the two young couple young men were
imprisoned for almost ten years
I talked to President Putin Putin Rica
privately mr. president
this is not acceptable and I explained
my position then finally President
Metallica said that I do not agree with
your point and there are still some some
present who do not agree at all with all
this as many delegations have walked out
it's a very sensitive issue then finally
she said even though I do not agree with
your position since you are the second
general you are talking to me like this
very appeal you are appealing to me I
will take necessary action I will just
release them I didn't believe that the
he would release them on the very day I
thought that she might take some times a
month with some than here to take some
channel generous measures then she
pardoned them on the very day I was very
much a grateful food to him but this is
just one example but there are tens of
thousands of people who are suffering UN
is
taking these very serious decisions and
will continue to to continue to ensure
that all the people's human rights will
be promoted and protected
that's my assurance and commit to that
thank you very much thank you yes good
afternoon mr. ban ki-moon first of all
thank you very much for coming today my
name is Juan Ramirez and I'm studying
political science international politics
and human rights here at Columbia
University and my question is more about
what is your recommendation for students
or so deciding on their career paths and
for students who want to make the
greatest most extensive long-lasting
change in on an international level this
summer I'll be working to be the
coordinator for a Spanish and French GED
program as well as working with an NPO
that works to employ high-skilled
immigrants and although the work at the
local level such as these programs are
very important my question to you is
where do you think is the best venue for
long lasting international change is it
through our national governments and
diplomacy is it - through the the UN
Network and or is it through NGOs and
NPOs
what is what is your recommendation for
the youth and where should youth like me
who are so deciding where to put our
forces what do you recommend for us to
do when we address so many difficult
issues there is not the single answer or
there's no single actor this should be
done dealt with by all the actors all
together
for example even particularly these kind
of a human right issues should be
addressed and dealt with by all the
people it's not only government
it's not only the United Nations civil
society's NGOs they they can have a
bigger bigger voices and they can play
even more important one often grata
nations acts upon appeals from NGOs it's
not that we are not always acting upon
government's so United Nations cannot do
our job properly without all your
participation it's very important that
the students and young people you also
feel that you are part of this program
you can challenge your professors you're
challenging your Congress Congress men
and women and senators you can challenge
your business community leaders like or
civil society leaders I think you have
the biggest voices sometimes the
politicians they have to be very
sensitive to others because the
politicians are diplomats work on a very
delicate way because they have their own
national interest and there is a very
strong views held by other parties in
such a case that they cannot have proper
dialogue as you have seen in the
Security Council where they have not
been able to be United to speak out
against the Syria because of differing
views then as a media is human rights
activists NGOs and young people like
yourselves who can speak out why don't
you take action as a secretary-general
sometimes I may have to be very
sensitive to Member States because they
always take out as a national
sovereignty as number one principle in
such a case then we cannot have proper
dial
we are not united in such a case
therefore the point you have raised is a
very pertinent and all the stakeholders
all the community leaders they should
take part in advancing our common
challenges thank you I think in the
interest of time let's take two more
questions and that's all I think we'll
be able to do yes
hello mr. secretary-general just in May
of 2011 you're appointed executive
secretary on global sustainability gave
a speech in this very auditorium to the
threatened island nations conference
that was hosted by the Columbia Center
for climate change law in that speech
speaking on your behalf he expressed
your commitment to the plight of
low-lying island nations and recently
the global sustainability sustainability
report came out and there didn't seem to
be much of a mention of environmental
displacement specifically the plight of
low-lying island nations and this is
definitely going to be a growing issue
in the next half a century to a century
and it will threaten global
sustainability in many different ways so
I wanted to know what your thoughts are
on that
these days sustainability that that's
very important one even political
stability the politics should be
sustainable economic development
sustainable any policy like on human
right that should also be sustainable we
are now talking about this a
sustainability in comprehensive way
social sustainability economic
sustainability and environmental
sustainability these are three pillars
when we talk about sustainability
without addressing all these three even
one missing
you cannot say we are living in a
sustainable sustainable world this is
what I'm telling you
then for politics to be sustainable
there should be economic and social
prosperity to be supporting without this
socio economic sustainability supporting
you cannot have sustainable politics
this political situation becomes very
easily in stable as we have seen many
countries in Africa or elsewhere when
when there is no political
sustainability you cannot engage in free
Economic Development or economic
activities and social activities
therefore all these in turn
interconnected you cannot think one
another separately independently
that is what imaginations is trying to
achieve at this time I think thank you
and last question thank you for your
inspiring words my name is Nicholas
Tahari I'm from Argentina and as you
know Argentina has been requesting
dialogue with the UK concerning to
discuss the issue around the Falkland
Islands and the UN has passed
resolutions encouraging that dialogue
but the UK has persistently resisted to
do so so my question is how do you see a
role in this in this issue in this
conflict and how do you how can we be
optimistic about the the UN the
possibility of the UN bringing about
change when one of the members of the
Security Council fails to comply with
the UN's resolutions thank you very much
this is highly political issues
in fact my last appointment that just
before coming to Columbia University was
meeting with the Secretary General of
Oona's Oh mrs. Mejia we had a long talk
about this Malvinas or Falklands Island
issues and before that during last many
years I have had the meeting with the
president Cristina Fernandez of
Argentine and Minister foreign minister
timmerman or Valentin of course you know
with the British counterparts I know
that this is a very delicate political
issues between United Kingdom and
Argentina and I myself offered my own a
facilitating role and I remain available
for any mediation but normally this
mediation and facilitating role can be
effective when both sides come to me and
agree but unfortunately the postal sides
have not agreed and only one side can
meet at the green light and I'm trying
to see how I can help facilitate these
decisions those two countries Argentina
and the United Kingdom are very
important imaginations Member States I
really hope that this issue
long-standing controversial issue will
be resolved peacefully through dialogue
that's my my sincere hope thank you very
much thank you mr. secretary-general 11
thank you on behalf of all of us we very
much appreciate your leadership we love
your passion and we know that you're
working on the hardest problems on the
planet if anything you make university
presidents feel like we have the easiest
jobs in the world and that's really
welcome thank you so much for coming to
Columbia and change
you